This lecture is continued discussion of
evaluation of textual categorisation.
Earlier we have introduced measures
that can be used to compute the
precision and recall for each category
and each document. Now in this lecture
we're going to do
further  examine how to combine the
performance on these different
categories or different documents.
How do we aggregate them?
How do we take average? You see on the
title here,
I indicated it's called a macro average
and this is in contrast to micro
average that will talk more about that
later.
So.
Again, for each category, we can
compute the precision recall and F1 so
for example, for category C one.
We have precision
P1 recall R1 and F value F1 and
similarly we can do that for Category 2
and all the other categories.
Once we compute that, then we can
aggregate them. So for example, we can
aggregate all the precision values for
all the categories to compute the
overall precision and this is often
very useful.
To summarize what we have seen in the
whole data set and the aggregation can
be done in many different ways.
Again, as I said, in case when you need to
to aggregate different values.
It's always good to think about what's
the best way of doing the aggregation.
For example, you can consider
arithmetic mean, which is very commonly
used.
Or you can use geometric mean which
would have different behavior depending
on the way you aggregate.
You might have got different
conclusions.
In terms of which method works better,
so it's important to consider these
differences and choosing the right one
or more suitable one for your task.
So the difference, for example between
arithmetic mean and geometric mean is
that the arithmetic mean would be
dominated by high values, whereas
geometric mean would be more affected
by low values, and so whether you want
to emphasize low values or high values
would be a question related to your
application.
And similar we can do that for recall
and F score, so that's how we can then
generate the overall precision, recall
and F score.
Now we can do the same for aggregation
over all the documents, right?
So it's exactly the same situation for
each document or computer precision.
Recall and F.
And then after we have completed the
computations for all these documents
we were going to aggregate them to
generate the overall precision, overall
recall and overall F score.
These are again examining the results
from different angles and which one is
more useful would depend on your
application.
In general, it's beneficial to look at
the results from all these
perspectives, and especially if you
compare different methods in different
dimensions.
It might reveal which method is better,
in which measure or in what situations,
and this provides insight for
understanding the strength of a method
or weakness, and this provides further
insight for improving them.
So as I mentioned, there is also micro
averaging in contrast to the macro
average that we talked about earlier.
In this case, what we do is to pull
together all the decisions.
An then compute the precision and
recall.
So we can compute the overall precision
and recall by just counting how many
cases are in true positive, how many
cases in false positive, etc.
Basically computing the values to fill
in this contingency table and then we
can compute precision recall just once.
Now, in contrast, in macro averaging
we're going to do that for each
category 1st and then aggregate over
these categories.
Or we do that for each document and
then aggregate over all the documents.
But here we pulled them together.
Now this will be very similar to the
classification accuracy that we
introduced earlier, and one problem
here of course, is to treat all the
instances, all the decisions equally.
And, this may not be desirable.
But it may be appropriate for some
applications, especially if we
associate, for example, the cost for
each combination.
Then we can actually compute, for
example, weighted classification
accuracy where you associate the
different cost or utility for each
specific decision.
So there could be variations of these
methods that would be more useful, but
in general macro average tends to be
more informative than micro averaging
just because it might reflect the need
for understanding performance on each
category or performance on each
document which are needed in many
applications.
But the macro averaging and micro
averaging, they're both very common and
you might see both reported in research
papers on text categorisation.
Also, sometimes categorisation results
might actually be evaluated from
ranking perspective.
Now this is because.
Categorisation results are sometimes or
often indeed passed to human for
various purposes.
For example, it might be passed to
humans for further editing.
For example, news articles can be
tentatively categorized by using the
system and then human editors would
then correct them.
And all the email messages might be
routed to the right person for handling
in the help desk, and in such a case
the categorizations do help
prioritizing the task for a particular
customer service person.
So in this case, the results have to be
prioritized.
And if the system can give a score to
the categorisation decision or
confidence, then we can use the
scores to rank these decisions and then
evaluate the results as a ranked list,
just as in search engine evaluation,
where you rank the documents in
response to the query.
So for example, discovery of spam
emails can be evaluated,
based on ranking emails for the spam
category and this is useful if you want
people to verify whether this is really
spam, right?
The person would then take the ranked
list to check one by one and then
verify whether this is indeed a spam.
So to reflect the utility for humans in
such a task, it's better to evaluate
the ranking accuracy, and this is
basically similar to search again.
And in such a case, often the problem
can be better formulated as a ranking
problem instead of categorization
problem.
So for example, ranking documents in
the search engine can also be framed as
a binary categorization problem,
distinguishing relevant documents that
are useful to users from those that are
not useful.
But typically we frame this as a
ranking problem and we evaluated as a
ranked list.
That's be cause people tend to examine
the results sequentially, so ranking
evaluation more reflects the utility
from users perspective.
So, to summarize, categorization
evaluation, first evaluation is always
very important for all these tasks, so
get it right.
If you don't get it right, you might
get misleading results an you might be
misled to believe one method is better
than the other, which is in fact not
true.
So it's very important to get it right.
Measures must also reflect the intended
use of the results for particular
application.
For example, in spam filtering and news
categorization results are used in maybe
different ways.
So then we would need to consider the
difference and design measures
appropriately.
We generally need to consider how will
the results be further processed by a
user and then think from a user's
perspective what quality is important.
What aspect of quality is important.
Sometimes there are tradeoffs between
multiple aspects, like precision and
recall, and then, so we need to know
for this application is high recall
more important or high precision is
more important.
Ideally we associate the different cost
with each different decision error and
this of course has to be designed in
application specific away.
Some commonly used measures for
relative comparison of different
methods or the following classification
accuracy is very commonly used for
especially balanced
tester set.
Precision, recall, and F scores are
commonly reported to characterize the
performances in different angles, and
there are some also variations like per
document based evaluation, per
category evaluation and then take
average of all of them in different
ways.
Micro versus macro averaging.
In general, you want to look at the
results from multiple perspectives and
for particular application in some
perspectives would be more important
than others, but for diagnosis,
analysis of categorization methods and
it's generally useful to look at
as
many perspectives as possible to see
subtle differences between methods or
to see where a method might be weak,
from which you can obtain insights for
improving a method.
Finally, sometimes ranking may be more
appropriate, so be careful.
Sometimes categorisation, task and
maybe better frame as a ranking task
and there are machine learning methods
for optimizing ranking measures as
well.
So here are two suggested readings are
one is some chapters of this book where
you can find more discussion about
evaluation measures.
The second is a paper about the
comparison of different approaches to
text categorization and it also has
excellent discussion of how to evaluate
the text categorisation.